il a trop peur chronique de tomber dans
les fameuses préparation de kasparov
qui et surentraînés
1h17 il reste 1 kasparov contre 15
minutes à kramnik pour jouer neuf coups
il semblerait que les chroniques qui
trouvait une position inférieure qui lui
donne la nulle une position où l'avion -
mais que les noirs ne peuvent pas
transformé il a sacrifié son pion
volontairement chronique pour éviter de
continuer à souffrir sous les coups
d'initiative de kasparov
voilà la magie des échecs moderne on
transforme initiative un pion - est un
pion l'initiative voilà sur quoi ça
tient
matériel contre dynamisme c'est ça les
échecs de haut niveau aujourd'hui
kasparov a transformé son initiative un
pion de plus les kasparov a donné son
besoin de plus car nick a donné son
point de plus pour transformer
l'initiative de kasparov en pions avec
maintenant une égalité sur l'initiative
de dynamisme des pièces des deux camps
chronique a réussi à activer ses pièces
et on va probablement assister encore
une fois une partie nulle et aujourd'hui
ses chroniques qui s'en sort bien pour
la première fois depuis le début du
match
kasparov
a repris un peu d'initiatives dans le
match aujourd'hui
un tout petit peu d'initiatives
le problème maintenant c'est que ça va
poser le problème chronique pour mardi
quand il aura les blancs est-ce que je
rejoue la même variante où est ce que je
change
ce prof marque un petit point
aujourd'hui ne marque pas il gagne pas
la partie mais dans le combat il en
train de reprendre un petit peu le
commandement les rênes
c'est lui qui va y aller maintenant
d'euros de reprendre le dessus et de
pouvoir dicter à kramnik ses choix
d'ouverture
kasparov
et c'est de trouver la moindre chance
dans cette position de d'augmenter un
tout petit peu son petit avantage d'un
pion mai
et cherche un peu mais rien à perdre
espérons qu'il va tout intérêt d'autant
plus qu'il reste 15 minutes akram nique
pour jouer neuf coups donc très sport on
voit au moins en tout cas très
probablement joué jusqu'au 40e coup
c'est très probable il peut profiter
d'une gaffe de cramique qui a un petit
peu la pression autant donc il va jouer
au moins jusqu'au 40e coup ensuite
peut-être accepté de faire nul
alors qu'on voit bien le doigt le doigt
de kasparov qui est pointée sur son oeil
iso kasparov finger alors que nous avons
un arrivage de barges collectés alors là
le problème
le risque c'est qu'à ce mardi une
évocation réfléchir la casse parfois
réfléchir une heure et ça va être long
là ça va être l'enfer donc il faut
prendre des munitions
accrochez vous bien à vos sièges voilà
c'est dit laval a fait on est parti pour
une réflexion d'enfer de garry kasparov
art
sur les plans et voix il faut savoir
réfléchir fait sens très bien que ce nul
a égaré il acheva faire qu'est ce qui se
dit bon pour les sponsors je continue ou
nous c'est très bien que c'est nul
kasparov 17 se rappeler à quel moment il
a peut-être raté un truc
wade gratte un peu le menton
gratte un peu le mans alors que gareth
les spurs se gratte le menton donc la
morgue n'en peut plus et ils se jettent
proprement sur les tabloïds chocolat
test donc voilà c'est important ce qui
se passe en ce moment là c'est vrai que
stéphane on peut dire qu'on a un plan
bout de temps quand même
saric ça risque de durer garry kasparov
grâce à sa préparation a pris un
avantage énorme à la pendule et à plus
d'une heure d'avancé donc pour l'instant
il a infléchi 50 minutes pour jouer 31
coups ce qui est remarquable ce qui est
une excellente rapidité une excellente
vitesse de croisière
un peu comme un an le joueur indien qui
rappelons le est un spécialiste du jeu
rapide
kasparov lui habite c'est proprement
vladimir kramnik dans cette partie ce
qui nous donne donc un gary qui est une
finale avec un plan plus grâce à sa
superbe préparation qui a tenu une heure
d'avancé à la pendule
voilà une heure d'avancé à la pendule
est effectivement qui peut prendre son
temps qui peut bien épais chiens et on
le voit d'ailleurs dans tous ses plans
garry kasparov est en pleine méditation
ils se demandent ils cherchent toutes
les chances l'ogre de bakou qui n'a pas
tout à fait vieillir puisque on
reconnaît un peu son visage de quand ils
étaient jeunes très motivés toujours est
très concentré garry kasparov
le roi de la planète échec ça fait 15
ans qu'il est champion du monde ici joue
contre santander plaide me akram nique
il est mené au score il a un point de
retard mais là il peut saisir sa chance
etc et pièce noire puisqu'il un point de
plus ils ne risquent donc plus rien dans
cette partie peut juste gagner aucun nul
en tout cas il n'a que des bonnes
options garry kasparov les pieds qui
bouge
ah oui alors les pieds là qu'ils sont
bien en qui sont derrière la chaise en
fait qu'ils sont complètement derrière
la chaise
il est très très tendue garry kasparov
mais en même temps ça tourne ça tourne
dans sa tête plein de possibilités pour
f4 le dernier coup de la lumière
chronique qui nous permet de dire qu'on
ne sait pas comment kasparov va passer
effectivement c'est le problème
actuellement beaucoup de possibilités à
l'informatique
on y mentionne une possibilité
intéressante le coup à 17 h 5
voilà c'est ce coup là pour éviter tout
rejet caf qui a l'air vraiment tout
simplement trop fort mais le problème de
la fin qui évidemment stéphane c'est que
là les blancs peut jouer h4 tout
simplement du nom alors j'ai quatre noms
g4 il faut oublier au plus vite
puisque c'est pas absolument pas
positionnelle g4 s'affaiblir et beaucoup
trop les cases blanches
donc ça ce n'est pas envisageable il n'y
a apparemment pas de justification
tactique
en revanche le coût hk pluie eh ben il
est plutôt bienvenu puisque là
maintenant ça va être défense facilement
au kram nique avec les pions de caspar
qui ne peuvent plus bouger kasparov a
joué concours stéphane et louis tour des
coup de théâtre quelle est l'idée de ce
coup que se passe-t-il sur tours g4
c'est la grande inconnue
je ne comprends pas je ne comprends pas
ce qui est vulgaire kasparov n'y a rien
à faire je traduis si moi j'avais une
idée par exemple j'ai 5 g simple il faut
montrer l'échiquier démonstration peu ch
4 c'est important j'ai 5 h 4 rue f 7
tours g4 à l'image des bleus ndlr une
façon se laisse pas intimider chronique
et espoirs va jouer g5 la robella il
faut qui lui valait il n'y a pas de
choix kasparov là sinon c'est en ligne
c'est pas bon sinon il va donc changer
ça sinon elle reste concentrée pourquoi
bien parce qu'il veut envisager toutes
les conséquences du schmilblick et sur
g5 aprh 4 on ne voit pas on ne voit
vraiment pas la pointe de kasparov
c'est possible que ce soit bientôt
terminée stéphane pons piège et qui
piègent peut-être de gaz par an il a
joué crânement tout de suite ouais c'est
agace peur de jouer
il reste quatorze minutes à kramnik pour
jouer huit coups
ce que kaspar pourrait pas faire un
piège un jour poussé vite un piège tout
à fait subtil malheureusement qui
aboutit au final légèrement inférieur
pour les noirs au taux plancher cet or a
expliqué tour ses sept tours ses sept
tours prendre trop bons coups oui c'est
du lourd effectivement
je me joins au classement of this qu'il
a vu kasparov mais on se le demande il a
joué très vite tout redémarrer chronique
et il est nerveux aujourd'hui 1 pour la
première fois depuis le début du match
cramique nerfs 2 ils n'arrêtent pas de
se ronger les ongles c'est ça c'est un
signe extérieur qu'on lui avait quand on
n'avait pas encore vu sa cote est en
effet revenu alors il est revenu en
courante et ce paraphe la radio qu'un
bluff y ait à strophes et arrivait très
très vite bon là il va prendre sont
plongés la l'option qui est devant lui
l' devant sa main droite et il va la
lancer deux casses vous allez voir ça en
direct un il veut peut jouer pouces et 8
1 6 6 1
comment maintenant il m'a paru assez
vite engagé 5 ça a l'air d'être
complètement annulant eloi j'espère
qu'après 4 on ne voit pas la pointe de
kasparov mais j'ai néanmoins quelques
idées et là on a pris les blancs
prennent g freche des cinq noms mais
c'est clair que je suis 4e joue et h5
kasparov
non puisque ce nom mais pas tout de
suite s'ils arrivent à jour os 7
ouais les suffrages projet 5 h 5 il a dû
rager six échecs stéphane avec un
avantage blanc un édifice
non on ne sait pas ce qu'il veut jouer
dirigé six échecs avec la navigation que
montrer les jt de partage blanc ah oui
alors la voilà la position etc ramener
un jouet d'un coup h 2 h 4 qui récupère
le pion aux et on voit mal ce tout à
fait incroyable incroyable ce qui est en
train de se produire poussé vite poussé
vite à une proposition intéressante ça
c'était fou et 4 x 4 7 en prison quand
même ah oui oui vous éviterez sa vie de
ces mieux la menace ou cinq qui
attaquera de pièces le pub le fou des
4es à tour au g4 est là notre ami
informatique mentionne le couffo f6
ressources tout à fait logique mais sur
cinq lequel sont faits dans toutes les
tours ans au théâtre
ah oui d'accord et tout est attaqué donc
plus de problème
non ça va être nul ça va être nul là ça
va être nul après ce coup de gaz par an
à moins que kasparov et vu quelque chose
h 4 rue marc bloch et même la fait se
sont jeté un regard travail qu'a proposé
le nom ses fans un nom
je sais pas si je vais pousser vite aux
îles même prétendu que ce soit en plat
attaque up calcul
que si peu mais calculé le f77 la coque
rami qui va faire il prend angers 5
bah oui évidemment ah oui alors
évidemment la pression tranche de
saintes ces femmes sûres proches et
saintes ont validé l'option gène n'est
pas en prise puisque le fou des 4 as oui
bien sûr briquet mais sûr c'est
important
ouais mais sur un méga soit maintenant a
fait ça pour activer son renvoi alors
ils pouvaient l'activer c'est un échange
des pions c'est clair qu'à ce corps vous
voulez activer son roi elle le regarde
kasparov
curieuse sept minutes à crown est très
curieux sept coups très curieuse très
curieuse parce qu'elle fait kasparov
chez think roi l'isère d'une zone parti
de son avantage
qu'est ce qui se passe sur dur en 3g 6h
prend et après le nom jour j si c'est ça
et on rêve 5 qui gagne du temps sur la
tour peut-être c'est ça l'idée de nos
questions je ne comprends pas bien la
version prend à lui 5
ce projet cinq cdc les 5 que l'on là il
va reprendre à reprendre aussi sur la
pointe du siècle là évidemment ligne
blanc maintenant je verrais bien fou
c'est 5 pourquoi on va montrer la
position tout de suite actuelle
chronique est tendue je vais revivre
tous ces cinq personnes position j'aime
bien ce coup ci c'est vrai on a
l'impression que la tour blanche ne peut
pas trop joué là a pris 1,5
oui ou alors peut-être dans le foot
c'est ça que c'est pas mal mais
peut-être qu'on peut joueur ou h2o qui
est assez logique aussi toute sa logique
avec qui des fous ces cinq étrangers 3
puis 2 x 3 oui voila je préfère rage 2
parce que la tour sinon elle est restée
stable pour g3 menacera les changes des
taux et là on reviendra de la casse et 5
à la case de 3 pour pilonner rupture g5
ça ça peut être un plan pour ramener des
beaucoup de temps mais d'une arme
ouais rouages de salaire pas mal ouais
j'ai mis en rage dehors
en tout cas pour l'instant l'opposition
c'est celle là les trois se lève
ça c'est l'intox du sign of white sox
ouais parce que la crown kramnik en
minutes pour jouer cinq coups et
attention attention si vous jouez six
coups
onze minutes à trani pour jouer six
coups il est en dessous de la barre des
2 minutes par coup contre 1h06 à
kasparov c'est énorme
kasparov n'a quasiment pas réfléchi dans
cette partie il n'a fait que se rappeler
ses analyses
c'est là que les parties d'échecs se
gagne souvent à la maison on a trouvé
une variante intéressante à jouer et on
se reprend l'adversaire avec une
variante déjà calculé ça évite de perdre
du temps le jour de la partie autres
possibilités stéphane qu est la plus
intéressante c'est le court à f2 bref de
mai
il ya tour échec non tour échec 3-3 au 3
rue de rome
il faut laisser la place aux trois pour
le foot hebdo dans cette position sur
toi géant prendrait le pion g2 alors
après tout ranger 2 et bien cellules
faciles
pourquoi vous faites au pro tour on
échange et les tours vous prend et
maintenant les cases à contrôler donc on
met le fond assez simple et quelques
cases il faudra contrôler ces deux cas
cela parce que c'est les cases ou
lecture vont avancer indiscutablement et
bien donc il suffira de mettre le doigt
sur cette case en f2 oui et ensuite ça
sera une nulle vraiment très très facile
ces techniques est très simple les deux
joueurs savent faire nul dans cette
position ils savent que c'est nul ça ne
présente aucune difficulté technique
donc trois f2 est intéressant puisque
autour des deux échecs on peut jouer
avec fo 3 1 re et 3 alors pas toujours
la menace ici stéphane c'est fou et 3 et
je mange de plongée 5 quoi oui non mais
d'accord mais nan mais surtout riche est
qu'on peut jouer un rôle trois tours à
chaque cours le 3 mai à ce moment là la
tour peut partir alors que surprendre un
boom fou à trois roues d'appareils quick
n ya pas fou et 3 1 mis d'accord
oui on joue après ouais mais ben oui
ouais bref de c'est le bon coup pour
chronique il l'a vu calcul chronique
il lui reste attention faut pas qu'ils
se trompent parce que la finale et
peut-être mieux mais s'ils se trompent
attention attention krainik pas droit à
l'erreur
je suis pas sûr de ton truc là parce que
la aaa à aa
on est 2 ème et oui moyen de le ramener
ouais ouais ouais ouais l2 il le tient
avec la menace fou ou trois attaquants
le pion g5 donc la case sport que je
rage et si c'est sur faut trois pour des
mais oui c'est pas très prometteur voilà
ce serait complètement nouvelle
en f2 alors kasparov peut jouer autour
des deux échecs sur quoi kramnik jours
heureux
pas très convaincant quand même cette
histoire
mais si ça doit être ça doit être ça de
menacer de faire du house is part of ou
n'y crois pas trop ce coup là il le paie
sourcil en musique chez nulle part of
c'est du cinéma actuellement en a pas on
a on a droit à une période de cinéma des
deux joueurs et notamment guy stephan
stéphane quoi chéquier démonstration
c'est possible dès novembre très
importante
oui ce roi g6 oui l'idée c'est de tenir
wallonie avec un focus sur photo ou
tourner 5 ouais on a toujours un peu
plus dans cette position il n'y a le
courage de 2 à wimereux devant la tour
d'abord et après il faut 3 la tour de
bouger et on voit pas ou peut-être en a
trois là et maintenant chevaux de troie
égale le pion guînes option j'ai senti
en ligne avec échec
donc si la ceni l'absolu la variante
proposée par notre ami électronique
offrant f6 petit move
ah oui très jolie fait nous a coupé un
peu vite n'a pas ce que sur un très long
way une fois explique t on mais surtout
replongé ce avec les biens pour prendre
trois tours prend 1,3 avec des chèques
de penseurs et en suivant été augmentera
le prix route et surtout plongé sans
problème il ya pour fc la toile est
attaqué c'est horrible donc qui est
effectivement une variante un peu
technique certes mais qui marche pas
donc kasparov va jouer roi g6 idées dans
cette position qui casse parfait une
barmaid son bras sur la cage et 6 c'est
très très probable
non il fait aux riches cheikhs inas
autour de nous et chacun bah oui il va
prendre l'option et venge en mesurant
pas stéphane je n'y crois pas
revin sur whaou qu'est-ce-qui giulia gt
sport au tour de trois noms ne soient
pas ce droit est mais il fait tout
reprend g2 mais non mais non pourquoi
si nul c nul c'est toi qui le disent et
nous lui on encore faire mieux la
médecine est le foot me reposer stéphane
c'est le les connaître ouais ce n'est
que les étudiants granik au moins six
chroniques jouer ça c'est qui les
connaît aussi excellemment bien
peut-être quelques conflits qu'on
dépasse pour ceux qui surprit white est
parfait tout à fait
surprenant peut-être trois ans on peut
bouger la tour on a deux avec l'idée de
prendre le chang'e 2 avec la foule je
vous fais 3 on a dit bon on a pas
d'échangé les pions c'est vrai les pions
- nadia oui c'est vrai que comme j'étais
enfant j'ai revu waouh c'est le coup
alors serein on va voir comment va t on
attendre ce que font les joueurs parce
que là on va remontrer link à savoir
sacrés voulons montrer les cases parce
que voilà il ya passé la position ça
c'est la position pour les stars des
joueurs la menace ils vont enfin
cramique peut jouer éventuellement le
coup droit eux
il a six kasparov joue la tour 1 à 2 par
exemple si on prend le pion ça serait
nul oui alors si on fait aura deux noms
roues 1,3 mais je peux aussi pareil ça
changerait puisque surtout après offert
aux f2 et voilà dans la même position
que tout enfant j'ai de toute façon
voilà ça va être nul
sam est nul dans quelques instants voilà
bah et kramnik échange la tour que
propose le nul mais parce qu'il a eu
l'expérience il sait qu'il faut pas
proposer nul c'est au noir de le faire
et kasparov va essayer il maintenant
qu'à soir lui aussi il sait que les
sponsors aime pas que ça se termine vite
alors il souffle même quand tu sais que
c'est nul il va jusqu'au bout en fait
ils préfèrent jouer un peu que
d'attendre au 5/5
quelle idée
et bien l'idée simple c'est que les
blancs ne peuvent pas avancer leurs
pions c'est ce que j'ai expliqué aux
fans savent a tenu tout de suite et oui
pourquoi suroît gestion sont des
domaines encore plus forte
pourquoi sûrement g6 qui va suivre ouais
bon je m'en fous on mérite joly est là
que se passe-t-il je ne comprends pas
sur wave 5 joue simplement wade 4 je
fais donc un barrage contre le roi noir
sur son aile mais le plonger il a
attaqué aussi l'option j'avance et je
m'en fous je fais fausse et 7
il n'y a plus de plan possible roger
sainte-croix grh 4,6 à manger sain que
je poursuis avec 3,3 et quand le roi
arrive on achetait pour soutenir le
changer et bien je contrôle avec le roi
et voilà s'il facile un vrai facile
cramique qu'est-ce que remplaçant contre
ça va être nul dans quelques secondes on
peut mettre en gros plan c'est très
clair bravo krainik bravo bravo krainik
qui fait nul tranquille il nous reste
sept minutes de jeu de coûts mais il
sait exactement quoi faire
kramnik fait nul avec deux pions -6 plus
fort que kasparov et loi
kraft est qu est ce qu a fait nul avec
comme points de moins mais l'ultra nique
il lui demande ce qu'il fait nul avec
deux pions moins quand il veut quand il
veut en fait kravis port de piau
kasparov
ah oui là soient enfouis bah oui c'est
terminé c'est terminé chronique est trop
fort la chronique est revenu s'asseoir
derrière stéphane ohlala mais oui et ce
qui peut pas faire roger 6
non mais bref 5 et roger 4 après n'y
peut mais y'aura royaux de toute façon
très simple ce fameux 13 500 m2
oh la la chronique tranquille isidro
autocar à munich
kolnik heureusement d'ailleurs parce que
là il était mal parti il a souffert
chronique aujourd'hui et se faire mais
il montre que lui aussi est difficile à
battre oui c'est vrai ce sont deux
joueurs très dur alors aux mollahs la
pole alors maintenant on gare il n'y a
plus rien là il ya péril à la cuisse
ouais mais tu as raté d'agencés oui non
en fait il fait un petit demain pour les
sponsors
elle fait un peu de cinéma pour la
presse et tout ça ici que c'est nul
depuis tic ou déjà
c'est d'une seconde à l'autre baboye
norme et où il garé dans les plans yapo
au bas mot au karaté il reste une heure
si tu veux gagner tu peux réfléchir une
heure tu trouveras pas plus
il reste une heure une a4 avant qui va
proposer nul c'est sûr il va jouer le
congrès si elle ne veut pas jouer trou
stéphane et va dire ni kyats ekram nick
va être non est obligé de jouer d'abord
non non non et non
on est obligé d'en haut niveau ça ne se
fait pas si si si si j'y suis obligé
il va jouer d'abord c'est obligé c'est
dans les règles on ne peut pas proposer
nul avant de jouer son coup et bien ce
qu'il peut faire une faute il peut jouer
os 3 proposait du lait la chronique dit
non non je fais trois points f3 je te
contredis à toi de jouer la règle et
êtes est la suivante on peut proposer
nul sur son temps l'adversaire n'est pas
obligé de répondre non je suis son coup
non mais là non mais là c'est une p soir
chine
il ne jouera pas de coupe les sports il
ne va pas jouer
je m'en a pris on m'a appris qu'il
fallait d'abord jouer et après vous
possible oui d'accord mais là c'est un
autre niveau quand même nom mais les
règles sont les règles
non non mais la règle que soit le niveau
la règle c'était ainsi aux propos tenus
sur le temps de son autre temps de
réflexion notre adversaire peut dire
joue ton coup d'abord d'iphone os 3 1
mais il n'est pas obligé il peut
accepter tout de suite si ce qui
évidemment va être le cas ici
donc bref gros suspense n'en voyais et
ramener crown est mené on peut toujours
face quoi on peut aussi on peut aussi
faire pipi sur la table et arbitre va
dire attendez c'est pas interdit
c'est interdit certains disent de moi ne
règleront et bien non il n'y a pas de
clause interdisant 6,6 d'uriner sur la
table c'est sûr que si une clause qui
dit que les joueurs ne doivent pas
intervenir sur sur l'air de jeu on en
enchaînant son sens sur l'adversaire
tout simplement la corée c'est à
l'arbitré de décider si faire pipi sur
la table est écrit que je faisais ça
pour être mieux régner dans la loge par
exemple effectivement on peut se poser
la question éventuellement non mais là
de toute façon une chose est sûre au
respect c'est là ça se voit il n'y a pas
de bluff
il n'y a pas de cinéma à faire c'est
archi nul c'est complètement nul ah non
mais je suis surtout les oreilles aux
réflexions n'y changera rien je
demanderai leur vie je suis sûr que
lesparre où va jouer
est-ce que tu rami peut lui dire sika
sport dit nietzsche a gravi les échelons
coup oui tout à fait ça c'est possible
et ça ça va énerver
ça va énerver donc il a intérêt putois
jouer et à proposer nul pour éviter
d'être énervé voilà de toute façon
puisque kramnik aura le droit de lui
dire de jouer son coup ce qui prouve
qu'il faut bien qu'il joue son coup et
que chronique ne sera pas obligé
d'accepter la nulle sans doute revient
voilà chronique attend la proposition là
mais est-ce que si kraft est ce que
quelqu'un peut jouer roger six proposés
d'ul appuyé sur la pendule proposé nu
les chroniques dit non non je le joue ce
possible aussi crédit peut la jouer
rien n'empêche les blogs continuer la
partie alors que les blancs font nulle
tranquillement hallucinant avec voilà
ouais il n'a pas joué le coup et
une halle aux draps vos parties nulles
brebis en neuvième plus chaud pour
kramnik mais finalement et oui il s'en
est bien sorti il la préparation de
kasparov qui tombe à l'eau on peut dire
à l'eau et aux anneaux en fait et qui
par contre risque de recommencer dans
les futures parties encore une partie
est relativement courte aujourd'hui loin
trois heures de jeu c'est relativement
court je n'aime pas jouer ça nous change
quand même des marathons qu'on a eus
puisqu'on a eu deux parties marathon qui
ont duré six heures et 6 heures et demie
oui c'est très long en revanche les
parties ici sont plus calmes sont plus
cools trois heures de jeu seulement très
jolie partie très jolie partie
préparation de kasparov très jolie
préparation kasparov contre attaque
dynamique
donc elles ont effectivement ne quittez
pas l'antenne puisque à suivre la
conférence de presse dans le direct on
exactement qui sera suivi d'un résumé en
anglais en résumé de 26 minutes présenté
par tenue kosten effet manque in
exceptionnellement tony kosten ce soir
va présenter l'émission
et ça sera suivi par un résumé stéphane
en français
alors que eric giler roms et les pizzas
excellent arbitre de ce temps le nôtre
en moi c'est un des trois arbitres en d3
1 2 3 richwiller américain qui a joué
une partie de démonstration notre jour
d'ailleurs jeudi dernier après le match
contre l'udc mcshane le prodige et
anglais eh bien pourquoi ses débuts
cette partie de l'insertion simplement
le public était déçu alors qu'on amène
les micros voit la branche micros sont
amenés on nous avons vu olivier brisse h
eures à l'écran ou de passer furtivement
devant la caméra c'est très cher olivier
qui organise régulièrement chaque année
le tournoi de vienne de bienne bienne
deal c'est en anglais non c'est un
allemand
c'est la ville bilingue voilà c'est un
amant et vienne
voilà moi ça cher journaliste suisse
aucun doute olivier brice a cherché la
vie préparation la préparation kasparov
quand même on envoie les deux micros f5
est terrible c'est terrible ce courant
f5 très fort très fort mais aucun doute
je ne sais pas si t'es sport leur joie
le doute est là mais ça a l'air sale
affaire nul au moins tranquille pour la
prochaine fois grammy peut être à fond
ah oui kralik sera préparée c'est sûr
alors qu'est ce qu'il c'est la première
fois que chroniqueur difficultés avec
les blancs oui effectivement
maintenant est-ce que kasparov est-ce
que chronique va réussir à ne pas mettre
cas soit en difficulté avec les normes
va pas trop parce que parce qu'il a
choisi pour l'instant que des ouvertures
passive kramnik qu'elle le coup mais
mais mais superbe un tonique la façon
dont il a transposé en finale voilà
alors que les joueurs vont arriver sur
scène et que nous allons bientôt passer
au son de la salle
donc quelques instants ces jolies
parties aujourd'hui un peu courte mais
joli kasparov a très bien il est
l'initiative des blancs est amoindrie et
même plus puisqu'il a pris l'initiative
mais cramique a très très bien réagi et
prouve que lui aussi s'est excellemment
bien défendre notamment la fin il a été
très très précis beaucoup tour f 4 et
3,4 c'est superbe
ça ne laisse aucune chance à garry
kasparov qui est le tour des trois pas
forcément le plus précis il faut dire
ouais peut-être puisque ici là nul s'est
conclue très la même que ce soit de
toute façon il a choisi une variante qui
fait des nuls vite ce qu'il voulait
aller se préparer pour la parité la
partie de demain qui va être une autre
paire de manches puisque la casse par
amphora les blancs et on a l'impression
et loi que kasparov est revenu dans le
match on peut le dire on peut le dire
avec cette préparation
la deuxième partie du match s'annonçait
plus plus difficile pour chronique en
tout cas au niveau de la gestion d
ouverture voilà alors qu'on revoie
défilé la partie et on l'agité des los
boys
on va pas ici alors là dans les joueurs
pour la conférence de presse peut-être
qu'on cible journalistes disent ils vont
forcément de demandes la question si
c'était une préparation
cette la question est qu'est sparrow va
répondre qu'il ne répondra pas à ce type
de questions ce qui peut se comprendre
et effectivement ça ne fait aucun doute
mais on restera exceptionnellement pour
y répondre
effectivement c'était une préparation
oui puisque là c'est quand même flagrant
ce qui s'est passé voilà eric gillard
vais chercher des joueurs libres et
sèche repasse devant la caméra dans le
casse parfait là et nous passons donc la
parole aux conférenciers aux
journalistes dans la salle voilà il est
plus à l'aise aujourd'hui kasparov que
jeudi dernier
aujourd'hui c'est lui c'est lui qui a
réussi à dominer le jeu et a montré
qu'avec les pièces noires ils pouvaient
poser des problèmes chroniques
kasparov a duré les trois fois notre
camarade over et goûtent notre les
familles 3,9
une facture est votre cas n'est de
écrite fight for cours l'été et 12h10
quatuor bottes games winter x games